[Música]
volodymyr si es que el presidente de
ucrania anunció la visita este domingo a
kiev de los secretarios de estado y
defensa de eeuu aunque washington no
confirma la noticia este informe llega
un día en el que rusia arremete con su
ofensiva sobre la ciudad de mariupol
también de bombardeos en el donbass
lleno de ésta con un saldo de al menos
14 civiles muertos tenemos informe
desdén y pro
los franceses en el extranjero y en los
territorios de ultramar acudieron este
sábado a las urnas para la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
este domingo en la votaciones en francia
continental en total cerca de 49
millones de personas están habilitadas
para votar
tractorazo en argentina el sector
agrícola salió a marchar en las calles
de buenos aires en rechazo a un aumento
de los impuestos que planea el gobierno
el ejecutivo argumenta que este gremio
se ha beneficiado de unas ganancias
inesperadas en medio de los altos
precios de sus cultivos en la economía
mundial
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias aquí en la pantalla de france
24 gracias por continuar con nosotros yo
soy juan pupiales día 59 de la invasión
rusa sobre ucrania en esta jornada el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
anunció para este domingo la visita a
kiev de los secretarios de estado y
defensa de eeuu algo que washington no
confirma mientras tanto moscú mantiene
el ritmo de su ofensiva no solo sobre la
asediada ciudad de mariupol sino también
con ataques sobre odessa al sur y
también elegirse en el donbass al menos
14 muertos civiles dejaron los
bombardeos en estas dos últimas urbes
veamos el informe de andrés granadillo
la nueva ofensiva rusa para controlar el
sur de ucrania o de esa la ciudad
portuaria está bajo fuego la ofensiva
militar desde el mar negro dejó varios
civiles muertos además de varios heridos
el comando aéreo del sur de ucrania dijo
que dos misiles alcanzaron una
instalación militar y dos edificios
residenciales en odessa sin embargo
rusia sostiene que atacó un depósito de
armas mientras el mariupol otro bastión
importante en la región del donbass
miles de personas se refugian bajo la
fábrica siderúrgica de gas hostal allí
están las últimas tropas ucranianas que
resisten contra el ejército ruso una
mariupol es como una bronca port en la
dirección de mariupol el enemigo sigue
bloqueando nuestras unidades en la zona
de la planta de asustar y lanza ataques
aéreos contra la ciudad incluso con el
uso de aviones de largo alcance daño y
verdad si los motores una unidad de
ingenieros ha llegado a la ciudad
ocupada para terminar la infraestructura
portuaria de mariupol arne pedro esto el
presidente de lentes que advirtió el
cese de las negociaciones y algunos de
los soldados era atacado por rusia y
acción bosnia
luz del mar y si nuestros hombres son
asesinados en mariupol y si estos pseudo
referéndum se organizan en nuevas pseudo
repúblicas
entonces ucrania se retirará de
cualquier proceso de negociación
o karina with this week y paramount
process en la misma rueda de prensa
anunció que el secretario de defensa de
eeuu anthony blinken visitará a ucrania
y que preparan la seguridad para recibir
al presidente estadounidense joe biden
en otro lado de ucrania en jarquín otro
frente de ataque los bomberos luchaban
por apagar el fuego en un barrio
residencial
y mientras tanto el presidente ruso
vladimir putin acudió a moscú a la
congregación de medianoche para celebrar
la pascua ortodoxa en la antesala de
este servicio del papá francisco había
pedido un alto el fuego nuestra enviada
especial en mi pro al este de ucrania
tiene más información de esta guerra que
avanza en su novena semana
en plena pascua ortodoxa y mientras los
misiles rusos impactaban contra la
ciudad de odessa ocho fallecidos contra
nikoláy efe archiv ni puro donde nos
encontramos el presidente ruso vladimir
putin acudía muy sereno a la misa
pascual en la catedral de cristo
salvador de moscú y es que no hay tregua
ni siquiera en estos momentos tan
especiales en la pascua ortodoxa para
ambos países el ataque de odessa sido
especialmente duro y ha conmocionado a
ucrania entera porque uno de los misiles
ha impactado contra un edificio de
viviendas y hay un bebé de tan sólo tres
meses fallecido selenski ha salido a dar
declaraciones muy afectado ha dicho que
no tiene ánimos de negociar en turquía
con la delegación rusa tras lo ocurrido
pero que si la guerra continúa no va a
quedar otro remedio que apostar por el
diálogo también ha lanzado un grito
desesperado de ayuda al propio papá
francisco para que ayude a mediar y que
pueda sacar a los niños que están
atrapados todavía en la acería de
mariupol mientras este país ucrania
continuar y armamento pesado de los
países occidentales y rusia que continúa
también en su empeño de controlar todo
el sur del país para unir el donbass con
la zona separatista de moldavia pero sin
embargo hasta ahora las tropas rusas ni
siquiera han tenido avances en la zona
del este en la región del donbass
cambiamos de tema este domingo se
celebra en francia la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales en medio
de la veda electoral de 44 horas que
rige para los medios de comunicación
franceses como france24 les hablamos
acerca del voto por delegación desde la
primera vuelta en toda la nación se
registran más de 600.000 nuevas
solicitudes de esta modalidad de
sufragio que permite a quien no pueda
acudir a las urnas y autorizar a otra
persona a emitir su papeleta en
reemplazo
de montpellier lyon y a burdeos
aumentan las colas de personas que
solicitan la delegación de su voto de
cara a las elecciones del domingo los
electores que no pueden acudir a votar
se organizan para que otra persona lo
haga en su lugar
es importante para mí porque es la
primera vez que voto y quiero participar
se han presentado más de 600.000 nuevas
solicitudes para delegar el voto en toda
francia desde la primera vuelta de las
elecciones en montpellier se hacen casi
300 solicitudes diarias la policía se
encarga de finalizar las solicitudes
mientras dos agentes se apresuran a
registrar a todos los solicitantes la
mayor parte del trabajo se hace en línea
y la policía solo tiene que verificar la
identidad de los votantes para luego
enviar esa información a la oficina del
alcalde recibirá la confirmación vía
mail no necesita hacer nada más estar en
parís el fin de semana pero todavía
quiero votar como siempre lo es me voy
de vacaciones de semana santa con mi
familia no quiero perderme la segunda
vuelta por eso es solicitado delegar mi
voto ya se han presentado más de dos mil
millones de solicitudes para delegar el
voto y es una cifra que va en aumento
los votantes franceses tienen hasta el
sábado por la noche para solicitarlo
hablamos de américa latina' en guatemala
la fiscal general consuelo borras
continua en carrera para la reelección
la alta funcionaria se encuentra entre
las seis últimas candidatas para el
puesto por raza es considerada como un
personaje corrupto por parte de eeuu un
país que le prohíbe su ingreso desde
antigua nuestro corresponsal andrés
suárez se tiene más detalles de este
proceso de elección
en un país donde los escándalos de
corrupción no cesan la elección del
próximo fiscal general de guatemala
exacerba los ánimos y la indignación de
la oposición en contra del presidente y
del gobierno de alejandro giammatei
porque la actual fiscal general consuelo
porra señala abiertamente por los eeuu
de encubrir tramas de corrupción
pareciera tener el camino pavimentado
para ser reelegida por otros cuatro años
por el propio presidente alejandro
giammatei al término de este viernes un
recurso de amparo de la corte
constitucional de este país
centroamericano logró incluir en último
momento el nombre de consuelo porras en
la lista de los últimos seis candidatos
para ir a la cabeza del ministerio
público pese a que la comisión de
postulación la había desestimado de este
cargo cabe recordar que el secretario de
estado de los eeuu el pasado septiembre
de 2021 incluyó el nombre de porras en
la lista engel por obstruir tramas de
corrupción investigaciones de corrupción
como en la que se le acusa al presidente
alejandro giammatei de haber recibido
2.6 millones
3 en sobornos por parte de constructoras
para el financiamiento de su campaña que
finalmente lo llevó a la presidencia y
será el propio alejandro giammatei quien
en los próximos días deberá elegir de
entre estos seis candidatos donde está
consuelo por ras quién será el próximo o
la próxima fiscal de los guatemaltecos
que asumirá el cargo a partir del 18 de
mayo
una embarcación que cargaba unos 2000
galones de dice el náufrago en cercanías
del archipiélago de las galápagos en el
pacífico ecuatoriano se trata de una
vídeo cuyas dimensiones se desconocen y
que según el ministerio del ambiente de
ecuador dejó una mancha superficial en
la bahía de la isla de santa cruz las
autoridades ordenaron suspender las
actividades acuáticas en algunos puntos
de visité explicarón ubicadas a unos mil
kilómetros de la costa ecuatoriana las
galápagos cuentan con 198 mil kilómetros
cuadrados de zona marítima protegida
a la embarcación se encuentra hundida se
han colocado las barreras de contención
se ha evaluado la aplicación de
dispersantes en diferentes sitios de la
bahía en coordinación con el municipio
se ha hecho el cierre de la playa de los
alemanes y evaluando la dispersión del
combustible en la zona de la bahía
academia se ha procedido a hacer el
cierre temporal de las de los sitios de
visita del parque nacional dentro de la
bahía academia vamos a argentina porque
es su capital buenos aires fue escenario
este sábado de un tractorazo una
protesta del sector agrícola que se
manifiesta en contra de un posible
aumento de los impuestos que planea el
gobierno del presidente alberto
fernández el ejecutivo argumenta que el
gremio cuenta con unas ganancias
inesperadas ante el aumento del precio
de sus cultivos en la actual coyuntura
internacional desde buenos aires en
nuestro corresponsal natalio coso y nos
entrega más detalles del día
la ciudad de buenos aires está
acostumbrada a ver manifestaciones
cotidianamente pero la de este sábado
fue algo distinta fue un tractorazo de
los sectores rurales que le reclaman
sobre todo al gobierno de alberto
fernández que no haya un incremento en
la presión impositiva para el gobierno
este es un sector que está viendo
especialmente beneficiado por los altos
precios de los granos en este contexto
generado por la guerra en ucrania y
considera que en este contexto
específico de argentina de crisis
económicas puede hacer un mayor aporte
el sector agropecuario considera que no
es el enfoque indicado que una mayor
presión sobre el sector es algo
equivocado y que ya es suficiente lo que
aportan y es una atención que no es
nueva es histórica entre el peronismo si
se quiere del siglo 21 en el que está
inscrita
la ex presidenta y actual vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner y el
actual presidente alberto fernández con
los sectores del campo los sectores
rurales que consideran que a veces es en
ellos donde el gobierno busca ejercer
una mayor presión para generar mayores
recursos para el estado una atención que
claramente aún no se resuelve y que hoy
en la ciudad de buenos aires- se vio
reflejada en este tractorazo así
terminamos este informativo quédense en
france 24
[Música]